hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be a Ramsay Bolton bonus video everybody
wants to see him die even the actor who
plays Ramsay Bolton was talking about
the way that he wants to die on the show
so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened so far just
because the way he said it is really
funny I'm gonna play this audio clip of
him explaining how he wants to die on
the show you think he should go I quite
like a dragon related death yeah and
some brutal dragon action fighting a
dragon and losing I mean however happens
it should be pretty grisly shouldn't it
yeah I think yeah I think he's got a
cover yeah I think he deserves it
absolutely not surprised at all that he
wants to die by dragon this is the most
spectacular way you could possibly go
death by dragon while being turned into
a white Walker
so the night's king is on the back of
one of the dragons turning you into a
white Walker as one of the other dragons
swoops in and eats you wall Sansa is
simultaneously cutting your bits off a
lot of you have asked why the show has
kept ramsay around for so long because
in the books he's a big character it's
implied that he's headed in this
direction the show's been moving so fast
naturally it's skipped over a lot of
that northern storyline so in the theme
of evil turning on itself Ramsay ends up
killing Roose Bolton in a very red
wedding esque betrayal moment hail Hydra
so naturally there are a couple logical
ways that Ramsay could go out especially
given the Battle of the bastards that's
going to be happening later this season
they've been teasing us with these two
giant armies that are going to be coming
up against each other so if you want it
to be realistic he would probably just
sustain a number of wounds and die from
blood loss and battle especially if he
was fighting in the front lines or he'd
get lanced or some typical battlefield
wound but screw realism the show is
probably gonna do something awesome and
one of my top picks for the way I'd like
to see him go is by dire wolf just
because his sounds are so precious to
him this season Dan and Dave have talked
about spoon-feeding plot and teasing
things to the audience so all those
hound related moments earlier in the
season just felt like setup that they're
gonna pay off later oh look we have our
own hounds too but there are noir most
dire wolves and they haven't eaten
anything today because Sansa is
dominating this Ramsay storyline so much
I don't know that they would deny her
the pleasure of not being there when he
does
I she got to watch Joffrey die even
though she played a role in that she
wasn't a big part of it it seems that
she's gonna be a much more active
participant in killing Ramsey whether or
not she actually ends up getting to
deliver the killing blow herself but let
me know in the comments how do you want
Ramsay Bolton to die on the show and I
know a lot of you've asked what if he
comes back as a white Walker
well because Jon Snow knows exactly what
happens to dead bodies that you don't
burn if the battle is completed before
white walkers come south of the wall
I think they'll burn the bodies
preventing that from being a thing
they're not gonna leave it as a
cliffhanger like oh maybe he'll come
back next season is a white Walker
I think they'll resolve that so that
next season you can focus more on what's
going on in the far north with the white
walkers but of all the villains on the
show I think they've turned him into the
most outright mustache twirling villain
which is usually a bad thing but because
there are so many storylines you need to
have one person on the show that just
everybody unanimously hates and wants to
die somebody that you can punch in the
face that isn't like a supernatural
force this is just a total [ __ ] we
want them to die we're gonna pay that
off everyone's gonna cheer it's gonna be
amazing the White Walkers we all believe
very evil force the night's king very
evil person wants to subjugate the
entire world from the mall and a white
spring that's never ending winter to the
earth but he started out as a man we
really don't know much about the
original night's king only that the
children of the forest turned him into
the night's king against his will so
isn't it hilarious that at this point
the night's king is a more sympathetic
character than Ramsay Bolton that should
tell you about the direction Ramsay
Bolton is headed on the show really he's
been the replacement for Joffrey in the
narrative the one person that just
everyone unanimously wants to see die so
they paid Joffrey off after a couple
seasons now it's Ramsay's turn he's
risen over the last couple seasons so
boom about time for him to go each of
the different story arcs has their own
antagonists depending on whose
perspective you take most of them play
it a little more ambiguously so that you
could take one perspective of the other
like there are a lot of you that might
sympathize with Margaery over Cersei
even though Cersei seems like the bigger
character some of you probably really
like the idea of euron greyjoy even
though he seems like more of the
antagonists so it's just a little more
ambiguous the one exception is Ramsay
Bolton but you guys can let me know
the comments do you think there's been
any point where the show has tried to
give his perspective like why he's so
terrible well you know what it is that
he really wants he's like the worst
version of Littlefinger someone who
adores chaos for chaos sake but till we
even know what he would do if he were to
take the Iron Throne like what would
Ramsay do would it just turn into a
bigger version of what's happening at
Winterfell right now or at Harrenhal
would it just turned into a complete
nightmare
there was that story that Roose Bolton
told him did I ever tell you the story
of how you were born I raped your mother
then when she came to my keep with you
in arms I had her killed
but I decided not to kill you I spared
your life that was probably the only
time the show ever tried to sympathize
with Ramsay like oh my father never
loved me he's the most terrible person
ever he doesn't care about anything but
himself but here's my other big question
do you think that they'll actually pay
off Ramsay Bolton this season or do you
think they'll just give us the middle
finger and make us wait til season 7
before we actually get to see him die
happy Memorial Day weekend hail Hydra
there's so many awesome WTF things that
happen this week especially with the
Captain America stuff that's got
everybody pissed off so if you don't
know what's going on with that I'll put
a link in the description I've already
done a Captain America
WTF video but there's new Game of
Thrones tomorrow if there's any specific
bonus video that I haven't done yet you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments we're still alike the
halfway point through the season so
there's still so many big reveals I am
so excited about the rest of the
episodes I'm still working on a preacher
video too so I'll try to post that
tonight if you haven't been watching
preacher it's just another awesome
really hardcore comic book show but it's
on AMC so while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my hold the door video and you can
click here to learn all about that
Captain America WTF that people are
really upset about thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you